mais d'abord le fait d'actualité le
week-end et ses répercussions en france
la cour suprême américaine a révoqué le
droit constitutionnel à l'avortement est
partout dans le monde des femmes et les
hommes se mobilisent en france aurore
bergé la nouvelle chef de file des
députés renaissance propose d'inscrire
ce droit dans la constitution gaspard
flamand
inscrire le droit à l'image et dans la
constitution et protéger ce droit c'est
la volonté des députés à l'ère où m une
annonce faite par leur chef de file à
l'assemblée ça veut dire que
malheureusement rien n'est impossible et
que les droits des femmes sont toujours
des droits qui sont fragiles et qui sont
régulièrement remis en cause je vois
dans les nouveaux députés qui sont
installés depuis cette semaine notamment
le rassemblement national et député qui
sont des opposants farouches à l'accès
des femmes à liv et j'ai je pense qu'il
ne faut prendre aucun risque en la
matière au sénat le groupe communiste se
déposent une proposition de loi déjà
formulée en 2017 qui avait été rejetée à
l'époque par l'opposition de droite et
du gouvernement les communistes
demandent l inscription du droit à l'ivg
et dans l'article 34 de la constitution
faisons cette cette proposition nous
demandons en 2018 un débat sur la
question et le gouvernement ne veut pas
entendre parler de faire entrer ce droit
dans la constitution donc là il ya un
changement visiblement de position c'est
positif à partir de mots il ya une
évolution mais encore faut-il que ça
passe dans les actes les sénateurs
socialistes déposent tous aussi un texte
pour inscrire ce droit dans la
constitution mais avec une nuance il
souhaite qu'il soit inscrit dans le
préambule un symbole plus fort selon ihs
global mans la philosophie des
interventions tant à l'assemblée qu'au
sénat rejoint en fait l'objectif est
l'objectif c'est il faut préserver
absolument le droit à l'avortement et à
la contraception que nous avons aussi
rajouté dans le texte fondamental de
notre pays pour que cette réforme
constitutionnelle aille au bout deux
options un référendum après adoption par
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat dans
les mêmes termes
ou alors le président de la république
décide de réunir les deux chambres en
congrès à versailles le texte devra
alors être votée par une majorité aux
trois cinquièmes
je vous présente mes invités bérengère
bonté journaliste essayiste bonjour jo
est venu bérengère auteurs de cette
biographie d'edouard philippe le sioux
publié aux éditions de l'archipel
benjamin morel constitutionnaliste
maître de conférences en droit public à
paris ii panthéon assas bonjour et
bienvenue bienvenue également à richard
wehrli bonjour j'ai deux correspondants
france europe pour le média suisse blick
et je cite votre livre la france contre
elle-même que vous avez publié aux
éditions grasset matthieu croissandeau
éditorialiste politique et est toujours
à mes côtés bonsoir mathieu on va
débattre évidemment de l'actualité de
cette semaine cruciale pour elisabeth de
bornes des mesures en faveur du pouvoir
d'achat mais pour commencer donc cette
proposition d'inscrire l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse dans la
constitution française j'accueille en
duplex anne-cécile mais faire qui est
présidente de la fondation des femmes
bonjour bienvenue auteure de tu seras
une femme vous l'aviez publié aux
éditions les petits matins j'imagine que
ce ce le fait d'intégrer ce droit à
l'avortement à notre constitution c'est
l'un de vos combats depuis depuis
plusieurs années peut-être oui
effectivement les députés les sénateurs
et sénatrices rappelle que cet essai des
propositions de des lois qui ont déjà
été déposés et donc ça fait très
longtemps qu'on demande la
constitutionnalisation de l'ibg puisque
pour nous non c'est à la fois une
meilleure protection évidemment et là on
le voit à quel point ça peut être
crucial à quel point il faut le faire
quand on a encore les marges de
manoeuvre pour les faire et puis c'est
aussi parce que constitutionnaliser ce
droit c'est le reconnaître en tant que
droit fondamental et donc c'est pour ça
qu'il a tout à fait sa place dans la
constitution ça veut dire que ça aurait
pu ou dû être fait selon vous depuis
depuis longtemps dans soit le premier
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron soi même
les précédents absolument ou même
l'éléphante constitutionnel qui ont lieu
avant de les pousser déjà beaucoup les
réformes constitutionnelles même sous
françois hollande on avait déjà poussé
l'on avait identifié en fait cette
problématique qui est que
droit ivg est aujourd'hui constitue
considéré en france comme un droit
simple on va dire or c'est un droit
fondamental et sa pompe ça doit faire
partie des droits suprême qui sont dans
la constitution et d'ailleurs on demande
également est ce que le droit à
l'avortement fasse partie de la charte
des droits fondamentaux de l'union
européenne
et ça c'est ce serait une garantie
encore supplémentaires donc oui pour
nous c'est un combat de longue date et
c'est important de comprendre que le
droit les vg ça ne peut pas être quelque
chose de conjoncturel c'est quelque
chose de déterminant pour les femmes
pour qu'elles puissent être citoyenne à
part entière nous devons être libre de
disposer de notre propre corps c'est
comme comme le droit je sais pas la
liberté de la presse a fait partie des
points fondamentaux en fait d'une
démocratie et non pas juste en fonction
de la majorité en place et bien compris
je vais évidemment vous redonner la
parole donc dans quelques minutes
benjamin morel qu'est ce que ça
changerait concrètement
d'intégrer ce droit à la constitution
concrètement à ce stade là pas grand
chose l'idée c'est d'avoir un effet
cliquet decaux grosse nous donne puisse
pas revenir sur le droit à l'image et
pour être tout à fait franche passé
partagé c'est à dire que j'entends les
arguments il me semble assez fondée il
peut toujours y avoir un recul en
revanche s'il ya mon avis quelques
points de prudence le premier point de
prudence c'est que par rapport à votre
reportage et une petite divergence ou en
tout cas en l'état il y aura il devrait
y avoir un référendum c'est à dire que
face à une proposition de loi vous
n'avez pas la possibilité du congrès
face à un projet de loi alors si on en
reste à la proposition doit berger et
bien il faudra un référendum et donc à
partir de là c'est donner beaucoup doit
aux anti ivg qui actuellement ne pèse
rien dans l'opinion donc là il ya un
danger je dirais de transformation du
débat public sur un thème qui
aujourd'hui apparaît quand même
relativement consensuelle le deuxième
point c'est qu'on ne sait pas ce qu'on
fera le juge c'est toujours le problème
avec les droits fondamentaux quand vous
un tué quelque chose dans la
constitution évidemment ça signifierait
que rien n'est fait cliquer sur libé g
mais en termes de délais et acceptera et
bien le juge va être amené à interpréter
des choses et on ne sait pas exactement
ce que cela avait pris cela va produire
ça sera pas forcément d'ailleurs quelque
chose de favorable aux droits des femmes
là dessus le jeu telles évolutions de la
jurisprudence est extrêmement
imprévisible des moments vous avez un
droit fondamental qui est à nouveau
inscrits et qui doit se conjuguer avec
d'autres droits le troisième élément
c'est qu'on a probablement un peu mais
interprété la décision de la cour
suprême américaine elle ne dit pas les
végétaux est interdite elle dit li
interdiction ou l'autorisation d'y vg
dépens des états or il faut voir qu'aux
états unis vous avez des états comme
louise consignes qui sont peuplés de 500
mille amis habitant donc ils sont des
microcosmes sociologique en france
l'idée qu'on délégué aux collectivités
territoriales le soin de légiférer sur
dives et g c'est évidemment une autre
planète le système fédéral américain est
pour nous notre planète je crois
beaucoup plus son argument qui était
avancé d'une inscription de ce droit
dans la charte des droits fondamentaux
de l'union européenne parce que là en
effet vous avez la pologne vous avez les
engrais etc il ya un vrai vrai sujet qui
se pose en termes de délégations de
compétence ou de concentration william
l'union européenne et les états membres
mais là il y aurait un vrai vrai vol
même si je me suis maintes fois c'était
en 2004 en espagne avait été savez ça a
failli être remis en cause à l'époque
bérengère bonté comment vous réagissez à
cette proposition de
doro berger d'ailleurs qui a été reprise
aussi par par l efi enfin voilà il ya on
parlera un peu de du jeu politique mais
comment vous réalisiez mcentire une
réponse
à matane panneaux qui me première lance
le sujet pour la france insoumis et puis
y'a une réponse du berger puis un
soutien de deux des manies de
d'elisabeth borgne est quelque chose de
moi d'une petite course à l'échalote
d'une manipulation politique qui
sous-tend tout ça qui me met un peu mal
à l'aise il ya évidemment aucun débat
sur sur le fond sur sur ce droit qui est
inscrit dans la loi dalo a baissé de 75
et je suis assez d'accord sur le fait
que le le enfin peut-être au-delà sur la
décision américaine moi je ne vois pas
en quoi elle elle change quoi que ce
soit en france veut dire quand on
connaît un peu le fonctionnement de la
cour suprême quand on sait à quel point
depuis mai 10 20 30 ans les ultra
religieux américain forme des juges pour
venir changer cette loi tout ça n'existe
pas en france et donc je l'urgence la
précipitation là me fait penser oui à
des manipulations depuis l'assemblée tic
on en parlera peut-être mais mais sa
naissance et ça se retourne toujours
contre le l'instigateur accessoirement
je vais vous demander votre avis dans un
instant richard werly mais je voudrais
redonner la parole anne cécile mais
faire pourquoi vous font parce que
l'avion vient d'entendre deux arguments
qui sont nuancés qui sont
circonstancielles et qui disent
peut-être que finalement il n'y a pas
besoin de le faire en tout cas où en
tout cas attention à pas plaquer les
arguments américains à l'europe à la
france qu'est ce que vous répondez à ça
mais je réponds que c'est justement
parce qu'on en a pas besoin là tout de
suite maintenant pour moi qu'on a encore
la marge de manoeuvre pour le faire
c'est pas quand on aura une assemblée
nationale complètement anti ivg qu'il
faudra se réveiller parce que là ça sera
plus possible en fait de l'inscrire dans
la constitution
donc on peut inscrire quelque chose dans
la constitution contient un consensus
large ce qui est le cas aujourd'hui un
consensus large dans la population et un
consensus large au niveau politique donc
c'est maintenant qu'on a le poids qu'on
a on a toutes les chances de notre côté
pour que ça s'inscrive dans la
constitution pour que justement le jour
où il y aurait un risque et bien en fait
on aura quelques parmi toutes les
assurances de notre côté et tout ce
qu'il faut de notre côté pour que ce
soit le plus difficile possible de
revenir sur ce droit et pour moi il doit
se combinent et évidemment avec des
garanties européennes mais mais je pense
qu'en fait et
ça peut aussi être extrêmement
emblématique est politiquement très fort
y avait un grand sens politique y
compris sur ce qui se passe aux etats
unis si la france fait pas en avant
je vous interromps je suis vraiment
désolé mais benjamin boré et morel
disait attention si ça passe par un
référendum
là on donne la parole à effectivement
des gens qui aujourd'hui sont ultra
minoritaires souvent suez je suis très
confiante sur le référendum en effet les
sondages il ya plus de 91% des français
et des françaises qui sont attachées ou
très attachés au droit à l'image et il
ya plus de 80% des français qui
aimeraient le voir inscrit dans la
constitution
donc en fait on est quand même sur une
opinion qui est très favorable ce droit
il faut pas oublier qu'un tiers des
femmes vont apporter au cours de leur
vie et que ce tiers de femmes c'est
aussi beaucoup d'hommes qui qui peuvent
aussi être plutôt en faveur de ce droit
à l'avortement parce que ça c'est à la
fois évidemment liberté pour les femmes
mais ça peut aussi permettre à certains
hommes de ne pas être père ce qu'elles
ne souhaitent parfois pas forcément donc
donc est quand même un vrai soutien de
la population en france et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut le faire maintenant et sans
joie un message à louvroil
internationale ceci est un message
mais richard wehrli il y a quand même
que ce risque pointait benjamin rôle du
dr kossi à référendum il y aura un débat
et on va se retrouver avec une part de
là
de l'opinion qui est aujourd'hui
s'exprime quand même effectivement assez
peu sur le l'avortement qui l'a orane
tribunes métalliques oui alors je
rappelle quand même que les deux
derniers référendum qui ont lieu dans
des pays européens sur la question de
l'avortement ont été fort heureusement
remporté par les pro avortement qui
n'ont pas d'hier puisque ça a été le cas
du portugal en 2007 et surtout de
l'irlande en 2018 le savez en irlande
c'est une question très importante c'est
même à cause le client l'avortement que
les irlandais n'avaient pas initialement
ratifié la première version du traité de
lisbonne ils se sont rendus aux urnes et
ils ont supprimé l'interdiction de
l'avortement qui figurait dans la
constitution donc un référendum fort
heureusement il peut se gagner sur des
thématiques comme ça mais c'est vrai que
le débat à ce moment-là donnerait la
parole et je comprends que c'est votre
argument de manière beaucoup plus
importante à tous les anti avortement
c'est une chose ça je crois qu'il faut
le prendre en compte moi personnellement
si on regarde l'union européenne la
plupart des pays n'ont pas le droit à
l'avortement dans la constitution ils
l'ont dans la loi tous les pays
aujourd'hui l'union européenne donc
permettre l'avortement donc je pense que
on est sur une situation qui ne mérite
peut-être pas de vouloir
constitutionnaliser à tout prix je
rappelle quand même qu'une constitution
ça peut aussi être amendé et regardez ce
qui s'est passé aux etats-unis c'est ni
plus ni moins de l'amendement d'un droit
constitutionnel
que viennent faire la cour suprême la
charte européenne des droits
fondamentaux
sans doute parce que là effectivement on
est sur quelque chose qui permettrait
aussi de légaliser ce droit ou en tout
cas de leurs racines et dans des pays où
il est actuellement menacée on pense à
la pologne mathieu faire venir
[Musique]
l'avortement mais une société saine
mifare pourrait peut-être nous et nous
nous le confirmer je suis partagé à la
fois je trouve qu'on désire tout en
légifère toujours mal sous le coup de
l'émotion donc c'est une spécificité un
peu française il se passe quelque chose
généralement sur le sol national un fait
divers on légifère en lacets pas sur le
sol national c'est pas un fait divers
mais mais je vois bien toutes les
réticences qu'on peut avoir et en même
temps je suis assez sensible à
l'argument d'un séisme ait fait resserre
sur le fait si c'est un droit qu'on
considère sociétalement et politiquement
comme fondamental autant le sanctuariser
le protéger parce que ne nous leurrons
pas on assiste aussi en ce moment et une
offensive religieuse tous azimuts de
toutes les religions qui se réveille qui
ont des choses a dit on voit sur le
territoire européen que ce soit en
pologne avec les conservateurs en gris
d'une certaine façon la u en irlande on
le voit aux états unis ça c'est pour le
ski et tout ce que le réveil en chrétien
et puis on a aussi une offensive
religieuses d'autres religions je pense
à l'islam donc je suis je pense que tout
ce qu'on peut protéger d'une certaine
façon de deux de nos garanties
républicaine et sociétal qui ont été
réalisés dans des moments pas faciles
d'ailleurs
on se souvient des débats sur
l'avortement au milieu des années 70 je
suis par contre les centurions je
confirme ce que tu crois effectivement
une erreur de ma part il reste malte qui
prohibe l'avortement au sein de l'union
européenne alors une voix ya plusieurs
voies qui remettent en cause l'utilité
d'inscrire ce droit l'avortement dans la
constitution par exemple elle est
intéressante parce que il fait parti de
la majorité présidentielle et non des
moindres le président du modem françois
bayrou en écoute
est ce qu'aujourd'hui un franchement
dans l'état où le pays se trouve avec
toutes les questions que nous avons
devant nous est ce qu'il est bon
est ce qu'il est utile de faire ça alors
même que à ma connaissance aucun courant
politique ne remet en cause la loi veil
est ce qu'elle est devenue par les
évolutions différents
juste il faut se souvenir aussi à propos
d'un autre un autre droit fondamental
enfin entre rim et
l'abolition de la peine de mort donc la
loi l'abolît en 1981 et jacques chirac
l'a fait rentrer l'abolition de la peine
de mort dans la constitution en 2006 de
mémoire
ou 2007 voilà enfin il la demande en
2006 et les faits et s'est fait en 2007
pour le son de ferries et le protège
aussi ça n'empêche pas de détricoter
c'est vrai on peut toujours changer une
constitution par la suite mais ça va
quand même les choses beaucoup plus
compliquées
est ce que pour vous il ya une petite
part de entre guillemets jamais ni même
de deux pièges d'une manoeuvre politique
derrière tout ça il me semble wikia inc
a une part de manoeuvre politique et qui
est toujours préjudiciable aux propos et
un instigateur quand on pense quand on
pense à la déchéance de nationalité
france hollande on est pas sortie
grandie de 2,7 de cet épisode quand on
pense emmanuel macron lui même qui a
voulu introduire le l'environnement dans
l'article 1 c'était une des rares
mesures qui reprenait de la convention
citoyenne
le sénat a opposé une fin de non
recevoir et ressort effectivement pas
très grand dit quand on utilise comme ça
le droit qu'ont triture la constitution
c'est moi je trouve ça ressemble à une
fausse bonne idée et encore une fois
dans la précipitation ça ne sait quand
même beaucoup une manipulation politique
qui est pas saine la menace d'une
assemblée nationale la majorité est
reine enfin ils ont 89 députés je dis
pas que
la situation est fragile et on sait
pendant par le son ici mais
est d'ailleurs le rn canton mais mardi
voilà le rn en tant que parti n'a jamais
remis en question le droit à
l'avortement encore une fois je vais je
ne dis pas qui a pas de menace je ne dis
pas que c'est pas fragile mais pour moi
c'est une fausse bonne idée et qui
sous-tend vi ou jean françois fillion
disais qu'il était philosophiquement
contre l'avortement il est je ne
reviendrai pas sur ce droit mais je suis
philosophiquement qu'on trouvait bien
que dans le débat peuvent s'exprimer
aussi des voix qui ne partagent pas
forcément selon là ça veut pas dire
qu'il est menacé mais voilà et c'est un
sujet dont on parle il ya un lobby en
tout cas anti-avortement quelqu'un aime
et qui peut sur les services aux etats
unis
je serais plus réceptives et très
réceptive à d'autres formes de soutien
au droit à l'avortement par exemple plus
de personnel dans certains services qui
en manquent il ya toute une série d'
alerte comme ça là oui franchement dans
la pratique des benjamins et je redonne
la parole à ray charles de points il
faut voir quand même que les juristes
ont construit des murailles de papier
ses murailles de papier un jour elles
peuvent céder si demain vous deviez
avoir une assemblée nationale capable de
voter un retour à l'interdiction de
l'avortement je donne pas cher de
constitution en réalité c'est à dire
qu'à ce moment là on ne sait pas c'est
pas une sécurité on aurait probablement
les malades si forte c'est la politique
fiction mais on allait probablement
atteinte elle d un tel niveau du débat
public qu'il est en effet assez probable
que ce soit l'ensemble des institutions
qu'ils soient remis en cause et la
notion même d'état de droit ce qui est
en débat actuellement et françois bayrou
n'est pas favorable à l'interdiction de
là d'avortement comme d'ailleurs
beaucoup qui aujourd'hui s'exprime sur
les bancs de la gauche et la droite ce
qui pose question c'est grosso modo
également l'emprise du juge sur ce type
de droit ce que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure c'est à dire quelle va être la
marche de contrôle du juge et qu'elle
portait il va pouvoir donner est ce que
cette portée doit être évalué par les
représentants du peuple ou est ce
qu'elle doit être évalué par les juges
est tout à l'heure vous parler de coup
politique oui c'est à dire qu'il ya une
volonté évidemment dans la majorité de
cliver dans l'opposition sur ce sujet là
parce qu'on sait qu'aujourd'hui cette
marge de manoeuvre et cette marge
d'action du juge c'est la même chose
pour l'introduction de l'environnement à
l'article 1er de la constitution
elle pose question sur beaucoup de ben
politique et là où c'est un peu
l'arroseur arrosé c'est qu'en effet ça
pose également question sur les bancs
même de la majorité d'où la prise de
position de françois bayrou donc avant
je dirais d'avoir un débat peau contre
l'avortement ce qui n'est pas en fait
réellement le sujet je crois qu'il faut
avoir ce débat sur aujourd'hui qu'est ce
que l'état de droit et quelle est la
portée légitime de l'action du juge sur
de tels droits allez un dernier mot sur
ce témoin ils sont dedans alors c'est
peut-être un réflexe suisse de
démocratie directe mais d'autant que si
le processus de constitutionnalisation
est enclenché les anti avortement
trouverez un argument à réclamèrent
défaire un homme pour le coup il
pourrait dire que sur un tel sujet qui
attendent implication à leurs yeux il
faut que le peuple puisse s'exprimer
autrement dit l'assemblée pourrait se
trouver en quelque sorte coincé par une
partie de l'opinion certes minoritaires
ont vu toutes les enquêtes mais qui
réclamait un référendum et ça
deviendrait à nouveau une crise
politique dont nous des de la france n'a
pas besoin en ce moment le temps que les
arguments une fois qu'ils sont entendus
peuvent possible par une partie de
l'opinion quand vous regardez les ongles
est les voir les référendums ne se passe
jamais tout à fait comme on l'entend
c'est l'hexagone et campagnes dans les
référendum partout à l'étranger compte
et cette campagne peut permettre à ces
groupes-là de convaincre peut-être pas
une majorité de la population je
parierais un billet sur le we have sur
le oui à cette réforme si elle devait
être soumise à référendum mais il est
probable qu'au bout du compte le score
du oui ce serait beaucoup moins élevé
que ce qu'il était que ce qu'est ce qui
était sondés au tout début du processus
référendaire avoue le mot de la
conclusion on ne sait s'il me faire sur
ce
vous dites prenons le risque
oui oui absolument et puis si le risque
c'est que ce ne soit pas très utile et
ben alors tant mieux enfin ça me paraît
pas être un argument
voilà énorme en fait pour pour dire
qu'il ne faut pas constitutionnaliser si
c'est une réforme qui n'est pas utile et
ben tant mieux ça veut dire donc la
société va continuer à respecter ce
droit fondamental et on pourra
s'enorgueillir
mais je vois pas en quoi ça a servi
c'est un argument qui détricote
l'importance de faire entrer les vg dans
la constitution merci beaucoup
accessible mais faire je rappelle que
vous êtes présidente de la fondation
des femmes voilà on va continuer déroulé
le l'actualité politique de cette
journée avec un dernier une dernière
information qui nous est parvenu juste
avant que l'on prenne l'antenne une
plainte déposée pour tentative de viol
contre damien abad le ministre des
solidarités alors jusqu'à présent le
parquet de paris avait été saisi mais
avait fait savoir qu'ils n'ouvraient pas
d' enquête préliminaire en l'état faute
de pouvoir identifier les victimes et
d'organiser une audition là ça change la
donne quand même matthieu croissandeau
is a changé de fos où déjà les deux
plaintes qui avaient été déposées puis
il y avait été classée sans suite ça
c'était pour une des plaignantes l'autre
c'est vrai n'a pas pu être identifié par
le parquet ce que ne souhaitaient pas le
faire et puis là s'est il s'agit du
troisième fin de la troisième victime
présumée qui a témoigné dans mediapart
c'était à la mi juin pour raconter une
scène de d'agression sexuelle et donc de
viol à ses yeux
notamment dans une fête lors d'une fête
chez damien abad qu'est ce que ça change
à mes yeux ça change
beaucoup de choses et notamment la
future place de damien abad au
gouvernement parce qu on se souviens
d'une phrase qui était prononcée par
elisabeth bornes quand elles avaient été
interrogées la première fois sur le ce
sur cette affaire et l'avait dit s'il ya
des éléments nouveaux
alors on prendra les mesures qui
s'imposent aussi un secret de
polichinelle qu'elle est très embêté par
cette affaire'' abad qu'elle ne voulait
plus la présence de damien abad au
gouvernement et donc c'est lui fournit
une certaine façon un argument sur un
plateau pour pour ressortir damien abad
de l'équipe gouvernement rebelle en
jargon on peut
prendre la décision évidemment avant
qu'elle soit fait a commenté l'addition
en caux.le soient prises mais mais là il
ya une fenêtre d'opportunité assez
évidente avec le remaniement ait eu
malgré tout c'est effectivement comme
comme mathieu le disais c'est une
puisqu'elle a dit qu'il fallait un
élément nouveau il y en a un là
n'oublions pas néanmoins qu' il ya les
précédents
gérald darmanin nicolas hulot ddd ans
couverte des situations de ces durs
complexes mais je veux dire c'est un
contexte qui n'a jamais amené le
président macro et son premier ministre
de l'époque a décidé de ce genre de mise
à l'écart donc
peut-être que c'est enfin le moment avec
une cause du quinquennat une première
ministre qui dit qu'elle dédie son
mandat aux femmes aux petites filles
et que c'est quand même une cause à ses
centrales à un moment il faut quand même
que les actes suivront va rappeler
évidemment que s il ya de la présence en
dix ans on a fait tout un débat sur ce
thème dans cette émission et qui était
qui était passionnant benjamin morel que
voilà on se retrouve parfois dans cette
émission c'est pas notre objectif ne
court pas après l'actualité mais ça
c'est un potentiellement un fait
politique de la semaine on peut pas
passer à côté ça peut être un fait
politique en effet c'est à dire que il
ya la présomption d'innocence est
normalement un homme politique ou une
femme politique qui est inculpé ne
devrait pas avoir à démissionner et puis
un fait politique le fait politique
conduit à fragiliser un gouvernement dès
lors que vous avez une mise en
accusation on avait trouvé un modus
vivendi qui était plutôt opérant c'était
la jurisprudence balladur bérégovoy avec
la mise en cause est un examen à l'est
la démission étant donné qu emmanuel
macron a rompu cette jurisprudence avec
françois de rugy avec eric dupond
moretti en tirer les cartes en lin et en
gardant l'autre aujourd'hui elle figure
opposé est donc la seule règle qui monte
c'est grosso modo en quoi le ministre en
question va pouvoir peser ou pas sur le
gouvernement on sait que vu la situation
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale vu
les oppositions au fait que damien abad
reste et au vu du peu qu'ils apportent
aujourd'hui dans les rangs de l air
c'est à dire personne à part lui même et
bien l'intérêt politique de garde et
damien abad est à peu près nulles donc
il est en effet assez probable que le
prochain remaniement ne sont pas très
favorables un mot là-dessus richard
berry et j'ajoute que depuis le début
moi ce que je n'ai pas compris c'est le
ministère qui lui a été confié le
ministère des solidarités c'est quand
même le ministère des souffrances c'est
quand même le ministère on doit venir en
aide à des gens qui sont en difficulté
et donc à savoir que le ministre est
accusé de viol et que maintenant il ya
une nouvelle plainte je crois que c'est
totalement contradictoire avec l'action
publique menée dans son ministère
vous nous dites ça rend son ministère
quasi impossible et vont ériger 6 il a
déjà sans doute commencer il rencontre
en permanence des associations de gens
qui sont en situation soit de
vulnérabilité soit de grande souffrance
comment faire quand on est accusé par
ailleurs je pense que c'est
politiquement intenable
autre thème dans ce débat la mission que
le prêt en république a confié à elisa
bhl born sonder les partis d'opposition
du parti communiste aux républicains et
l'air pour voir si un accord de
gouvernement et possible mathieu
pourquoi
emmanuel macron at il finalement
puissance et qui s'est posé la question
maintenu les avens bande à son poste en
raison symbolique qui est difficile à
reconnaître tel quel doigt par
l'exécutif mais qui a joué il était très
difficile pour le président de
république de remercier la première
femme premier ministre depuis trente ans
après un mois de
d'existence soit c'était d'autant
qu'elle n'avait pas brillé mais n'a pas
non plus démérité particulièrement et
que c'était franchement injuste de lui
imputer la majorité relative aux
législatives peut-être que ça s'est
passé plutôt à l'elysée qui avait qu'à
matignon si on cherche des
responsabilités et puis en plus les
mêmes qui réclame aujourd'hui un vote de
confiance pour avoir la tête d isabelle
bande mais je vous fiche mon billet
qu'ils auraient évidemment on dit
qu'elle rompe cet exécutif a décidément
du mal avec les femmes en 95 avec
quelqu'un qui vous connaît bien juppé
oui mais nommé douze femmes ministres en
mer et et puis au mois de novembre il
avait plus que trois ça lui avait
évidemment coller à la peau et ensuite
une raison politique dans cette
situation inédite de majorité relative
aucun profil ne s'imposait vraiment en
fait souvent le premier nice c'est le
fruit d'une situation politique dans
rapport de force d'une coloration si
vous aviez une majorité qui avait
basculé qui était qui étaient dévolues à
l'ancienne opposition voilà les rues
squares et une cohabitation enfin c'est
nous serons réunis sur l'île et il est
souvent le fruit d'une situation
politique est là la situation politique
elle est pas clair n'en déplaise à
françois bayroux qui guignait le poste
et réclamé un profil comme le sien le
profil de la première ministre qui n'est
pas sans doute le plus flamboyant mais
plutôt plus discrète elle mérite d'être
moins urticantes pour aller chercher çà
et là des députés pour voter un texte
sans offrir forcément une victoire
politique à quelqu'un qui pourrait avoir
d'autres ambitions que son séjour à
matignon et puis enfin une raison plus
psychologiques de la part de la macro on
sait qu'ils détestent subir qui
détestent agir sous la contrainte
conservez-le isabelle borne à son poste
qui n'est nellen qui n'est large que par
le fait du prince je faisais et non par
le fruit d'un accord politique ou d'un
fait politique c'est aussi une façon de
signifier que le prince existe toujours
et que même si l'assemblée après une
petite coloration quatrième république
depuis une semaine nous sommes encore
bien sous la vème dans un régime semi
présidentiel où le chef de l'état entend
bien conserver toutes ses prérogatives
alors il faut bien lire ce que le
président a déclar é il accorde sa
première liste sa confiance dans la
durée voilà une précision importante oui
parce que
comme un rattrapage après cette
allocution où il avait oublié de
mentionner jusqu'à son nom enfin oublier
volontairement c'est une façon de dire à
tout le monde opposition et majorité
comprise inutile de vous exciter n'y
aura pas de remaniement à matignon pour
ce qui concerne le poste de premier
ministre devrait renforcer quand même un
peu la légitimité d isabelle borne qui
ne savait plus trop quoi à quoi s'en
tenir la semaine dernière même si elle
n'en a rien montré au contraire la même
plutôt fait fi des oiseaux de mauvaises
augures
handball s'est fait élire un homme s'est
elle a rencontré les chefs de groupe
elles ont dit froide cassante techno
essayé d'adoucir un peu son image dans
la presse ans en accordant des
interviews un portrait dans paris match
on voit bien voilà qu'elle qu'elle a
essayé de tenir le rôle toutefois il
faut le souligner cette assurance que
vient de lui donner le président reste
quand même étroitement corrélée aux
résultats qu'avec elle obtiendra parce
que c'est parvient pas à faire adopter
un texte son avenir sera nécessairement
compromis quelle que soit la durée que
le premier emmanuel macron bref et on
est en plein dans la semaine il faut
qu'elles seraient ses poils wii est dans
une situation particulièrement complexe
qui plus est sans doute la plus complexe
qu'on est connu pour un premier ministre
sous la vème république ça veut dire
savoir faire preuve de doigté pour
rallier les députés qu'il manque à sa
majorité selon les textes faire preuve
aussi de fermeté et imprimer sa marque
sur le gouvernement dont parlait tout à
l'heure à propos de la présence ou non
de damien abad ça veut dire aussi faire
preuve d'ingéniosité pour résoudre des
dossiers urgents comme celui du pouvoir
d'achat quelles mesures adopter et puis
faire froid aussi d'une forme de
résilience vis-à-vis de l'elysée fait
peut-être sans doute beaucoup pour un
pour une seule personne mais enfin s'il
réussit son baptême du feu alors là
peut-être qu'on pourra parler de d'une
richesse elle pourra s'inscrire dans la
durée bérengère bonté vous le présent
république garde sa première ministre à
matignon pour de bonnes raisons
il me semble que non il me semble
qu'elle est là et pour de mauvaises
raisons notamment le fait
qu'effectivement c'est con c'est même
impossible de sortir la première femme
qu'on voit à ce poste depuis guennic
récents au bout d'un mois et demi ça
paraît impossible il resterait dans
l'histoire de la vème république de les
deux gouvernements les plus brefs
seraient les deux tenus par des femmes
c'est quand même un vrai souci et on
peut dire c'est anecdotique non salées
pas cher c'est quelque chose d'abord
même à lui qu'on ne conduit renverrait
en permanence à la figure et donc c'est
un vrai sujet elle est maintenue
aussi parce que je pense que c'est je
trouve ça assez terrible mais elles
restent ils se gardent un fusible quoi
il est donc
la tâche un peu à mission un peu en
possible qui lui a confiée certes il
faut que l'on va effectivement les
cartes sont dans ses mains enfin sont
pas très nombreuses ces cartes et donc
ça oui ça ça ressemble à un fusible qui
pourra sauter un petit peu plus tard à
un moment où est ce qu'on parle beaucoup
de succès ces groupes qu'elle essaie
d'attirer dans dans une coalition et que
président voudrait qu'elle attire mais
mais en fait c'est pas c'est pas un
groupe de gauche un groupe l air et une
majorité qu'il faut continuer à fédérer
c'est ça va se morceler tout ça et ça va
être ça va devenir évidemment au fil des
textes de plus en plus compliquée à
manoeuvrer et donc là effectivement
c'est la suite de l'histoire le succès
éventuel de dans l'instant ne prédit en
rien la suite c'est olivia les oies la
porte parole du gouvernement qu'il
disait la semaine dernière pour danser
le tango faut être deux richard vers
l'iss c'est aussi cette semaine c'est
aussi un une sorte de test si on peut
dire pour les oppositions oui évidemment
parce que il va falloir qu'elle démontre
ce qu'elles sont capables de faire si
elles sont capables effectivement
d'éviter ce que vous appeliez la
l'éparpillement de certains députés
parce que ces députés qui rejoindrait la
majorité ils viendront bien de quelque
part donc les formations qui les auront
laissé partie en quelque sorte fait
preuve de leur faiblesse donc j'imagine
qu'il y à une discipline stricte qui est
en train de se mettre en place les
commissaires politiques qui doivent
veiller à ce que les troupes ne
s'éparpille pas quant à madame ben moi
je peux vous dire j'étais la semaine
dernière au conseil européen au sommet
européen
personne ne fait attention et ne lui
prête le moindre poids politique au
niveau européen c'est à dire que tout le
monde a compris qu'elle était là pour
être la première collaboratrice d'
emmanuel macron pour essayer de lui fini
les une majorité dont on pense qu'elle
ne tiendra peut-être pas beaucoup en
tout cas moi j'ai entendu personne dire
que ce genre castex avait plus de poids
jean castex avait acquis je dirais une
certaine n'ont pas dit non pas du poids
mais il était je crois il avait acquis
une certaine respectabilité et surtout
il n'était pas perçue comme étant sous
pression comme étant l'exécutant absolue
les mâcon ce qui est assez paradoxal
parce qu'au début c'est ce qu'il était
mais il avait réussi un peu à
s'émanciper de ce rôle et à exister par
lui-même elle pour l'instant la tragédie
c'est quoi elles n'existent pas du tout
par elle même et ça je trouve que pour
une femme nommée première ministre c'est
quand même très dommage alors parlé de
temporalité il faut lui laisser un peu
de temps mais sauf que emmanuel macron
leur donne pas beaucoup benjamin morel
si on regarde si on compare avec le la
culture politique de la négociation et
des coalitions en allemagne on vous a
fait la liste 2005 ça prend deux mois en
2009 un mois 2013 trois mois en 2017
c'est quatre mois et demi pour aboutir à
une coalition cdu csu et spd et l'an
dernier deux mois pour la coalition qui
est actuellement au pouvoir que peut
faire elisabeth bornes en une pauvre
semaine construire une coalition de
gouvernement probablement pas grand
chose c'est à dire que il ya trois
options sur la table soit vous avez un
gouvernement d'union nationale même en
excluant l es fier le rn ça paraît
impossible soit vous arrivez a construit
une coalition de gouvernement par
exemple avec l air en réalité c'est
mission impossible personne n'y a
intérêt aujourd'hui dans l'opposition
soit vous construisez des majorités à
dox à doc texte par texte ce qui va
probablement arriver il faut pas
paniquer entre guillemets j'ai
l'impression que depuis une semaine le
monde politique s'effondre mais en
réalité la conscient de la vème
république a été écrit pour sa voir que
quand michel debré l'écrit il a comme
vision la 4e et la troisième république
ce pas un effet de mode de scrutin vous
avez le mode de scrutin majoritaire à
deux tours sous la iiième et vous
n'aviez jamais de majorité absolue et
donc notre constitution a été écrite
justement pour gérer ce type de
situation
donc on est une amie isabelle borne
qu'ils ne puissent pas tombée via une
motion de censure parce qu'il faudrait 2
189 députés qui la vote et ils ne se
rendront jamais sur un même texte et qui
tient c'est très probable qu'il y ait
une elisabeth bande qui soit capable de
négocier texte par texte en allant
chercher un petit peu du côté du groupe
utile qui visiblement va se constituer
peut-être quelques eps de temps en temps
parfois l air en faisant que horizon le
modem et renaissance tiennent pas ce que
ça également ça va c'est très très loin
d'être évident la même ligne sur tous
les textes et surtout vote parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'il faudrait 2 189
députés à chaque fois faut voir que la
plupart du temps tous les députés ne
votent pas et que et bien si vous avez
des députés de la majorité qui ont ce
jour là piscine alors que de l'autre
côté la nuque a mobilisé toutes ses
troupes et le rn aussi même s'il ya une
majorité théorique les textes ne
passeront pas donc il va falloir
mobiliser parlementaire par
parlementaire au groupe par groupe sur
chaque texte est le vrai travail il est
là est la vraie difficulté d'exégètes
bornes c'est pas qu'elle soit de gauche
ou de droite c'est qu'elle n'a jamais
été parlementaire et que donc ça ça ne
m'en fais pas a priori quelqu'un qui a
la culture de cette maison ouais y'a un
texte qui pourrait servir de révélateur
sur la volonté des députés de participer
ou pas c'est pouvoir d'achat steve jours
doit vous pouvez nous nous rejoindre
l'inflation au coeur des inquiétudes des
français évidemment bonsoir steve vont
savoir sont les mesures promises par le
gouvernement par les attend toujours on
les attend toujours et c'est très long
rendez vous compte on est aujourd'hui
plus de dix semaines après le second
tour de l'élection présidentielle on
rappelle que le pouvoir d'achat était
présenté par elizabeth bande comme la
première des urgences alors petit
calendrier très indicatif thomas et qui
n'engage que moi qui ne suis pas
évidemment maître des horloges de textes
de loi vont être discutés dans les jours
qui viennent la semaine prochaine le 6
juillet le texte sur le pouvoir d'achat
sera présenté en conseil des ministres
il sera accompagné d'un budget dit
rectificatif budget qui contiendra lui
aussi des mesures de lutte contre
l'inflation et justement dans ce budget
il y aura une mesure qui a été confirmée
ce matin par bruno le maire la
revalorisation des apl les aides au
logement elles seront revalorisées de 3
25% le ministre de l'économie a aussi
annoncé la mise en place d'un bouclier
sur les loyers on va écouter
nous mettons maintenant en place un
bouclier loyers y aura une augmentation
effectivement de l'indicent 3 5% mais ce
sera pour l'année qui vient c'est à dire
que les loyers seront gelés on ne pourra
pas dépasser les 3,5 pour cent alors que
si on regarde aujourd'hui le niveau
d'inflation on pourrait avoir dû +4 ou
+5 de +6 c'est bien une protection taux
garantis sont aux français les loyers
n'augmenteront pas pendant un an de plus
3,5 pour cent
bruno le maire dit que l'état ne peut
pas tout que nous avons atteint la côte
d'alerté sur nos finances publiques il
rappelle l'objectif d'un retour à
l'équilibré pour 2027 et pourtant
plusieurs autres mesures de soutien au
pouvoir d'achat vont être débattues au
parlement dans les prochaines semaines
oui il y aura bien une revalorisation
des prestations sociales dès le mois de
juillet les retraites de base les minima
sociaux les allocations familiales et la
prime d'activités seront revalorisées de
4% à partir du 1er juillet coût de
l'opération au moins 6,5 milliards
d'euros pour l'année 2022 autres mesures
qui vont être discutés au parlement le
triplement de la prime macron le dégel
du point d'indicé des fonctionnaires le
versement d'une indemnité inflation pour
les plus modestes dès la rentrée il y
aura également une prolongation jusqu'à
la fin de l'année du bouclier tarifaire
sur le gaz et l'électricité la ristourne
de 18 centimes sur le prix du carburant
ou encore la suppression de la redevance
télé toutes ces mesures vont être
proposées par l'exécutif je me proposais
car ce sera au groupe politique à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat de les
adopter de les rejeter ou de déposer
leur propre amendement le premier grand
crash test pour les abattent bande ça
commence la semaine prochaine merci
steve pour ses explications
richard wehrli est ce que vous êtes
d'accord est ce que c'est ce texte là le
premier le premier crash test pour
reprendre l'expression de steve jourdain
pour isabelle borne et encore je
reprends la même question tout à l'heure
mais aussi pour tout finalement toutes
les forces politiques présentes à
l'assemblée qui pourraient se retrouver
sur une partie des mesures proposées ce
qui est certain c'est que c'est le sujet
du moment le pouvoir d'achat donc là
elle si elle doit démontrer des qualités
je dirai au parlement institutions
qu'elle connaît peu mais même s'il y a
précédemment défendu des projets de loi
quand même lorsqu'elle était ministre
c'est sur un dossier comme celui là
parce que c'est typiquement un dossier
qui peut lui permettre de transgresser
les frontières départ ça sera quand même
compliqué pour pour les autres partis
politiques de justifier un vote contre
oui sauf est ce ce que certains feront
sans doute a expliqué que emmanuel
macron est en train d'instrumentaliser
la question du pouvoir d'achat pour je
dirais réussir le pari de constituer une
majorité mais je crois que oui très
clairement pour elle ça va être un
baromètre maintenant la grande
difficulté encore une fois c'est de
savoir ce qu'il y aura dans cette loi
parce que pour que ce soit un vrai test
il faut qu'il y ait des vraies mesures
et donc là on attend bérengère bonté moi
je dis qu'il ya quelque chose que qui
est quand même intéressant à analyser
ces c'est cette prise de parole de bruno
le maire et voilà on a un beau vélo le
maire qui s'est quand même beaucoup
d'oeufs battus pour maîtriser les
finances publiques pendant une partie de
sa carrière politique et qui depuis deux
ans a ouvert les vannes comme jamais
quoi et donc on sent dans cette
interview qui a encore les deux qu'il
est un peu tiraillé entre les deux bruno
le maire
c'est le premier défenseur du en même
temps quoi cci c'est assez
impressionnant effectivement de alors
certains d'environ dans l'est dans les
interviews de ce matin aux échos à bfm
le rappel attention cote d' alerte c'est
pour la droite de 1900 milliards d'euros
et la hausse des taux d'intérêt est en
train de faire exploser le coût de la
dette etc voilà c'est un des messages
récurrent à droite donc ils vont bien
l'entendre et puis en même temps parce
qu'il cas de le dire il rappelé voilà il
énumère là
la hausse des apl enfin et toutes les
différentes mesures plus un appel à
total de remettre un petit un petit
chèque pour aider et pour réduire le le
coût du du litre de gazole ce qui est
d'ailleurs
personne n'en parle encore mais j'ai
évidemment que quand on a mis un
quinquennat sous le signe de la
transition écologique c'est une
problématique très très compliqué je
n'avais pas plaider pour une baisse de
la tva sur les sûretés sur ces
carburants vous pouvez pas c'est une
politique plus globale les cadrans donc
là pour l'instant il en est qu'à la
mesure pouvoir d'achat et il est entre
les deux passé c'est le parfait en même
temps richard wehrli on divise parfois
les 27 ans pays radin et pays dépensiers
ski et les radins c'est en général les
pays du sud fils qui s'appelle comme ça
ils vont finir de farine au frigo
frugaux oui je sais bien mais je peux le
dire a dit est-ce que ça choque un peu
plus fraîches et ils vont finir par nous
rappeler à l'orthodoxie budgétaire
c'est pas si sûr en ce moment c'est pas
si sûr parce que tous les pays si vous
prenez le pays frugal par excellence
celui qui est souvent cité ces les pays
bas ne sais pas s'il ya des
téléspectateurs néerlandais qui nous
regardent mais lors du dernier sommet
européen le premier ministre néerlandais
n'a pas évoqué cette question ils sont
tous sous pression en raison des prix de
l'énergie il y a dans tous les pays de
l'union européenne des problèmes de
pouvoir d'achat pour les classes de
populations les plus défavorisées
par contre la vraie question qui va se
poser ses buts au niveau de la banque
centrale européenne parce qu'à un moment
donné il va falloir que christine
lagarde elle ne pourra pas tolérer des
niveaux si vous voulez d'endettement
énormes dans certains pays et c'est tout
le problème de l'italie qu'on a connu à
un moment et vous savez qu'il ya quand
même une chose qui commence à flotter
dans l'union européenne c'est est ce que
la france n'est pas la prochaine grèce
donc sous ce secteur financier sous ce
prisme là oui ça peut tanguer pas sous
la question sociale et sur la question
d'allouer de l'argent pour venir en aide
aux populations les plus en difficulté
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat je rappelle le titre de vos livres
bérengère donc le sioux portrait à
biographie d'edouard philippe qui est
publié aux éditions de l'archipel et
puis richard wehrli la france contre
elle même ce livre vous suivez vous
reprenez la ligne de démarcation pour
partir à la rencontre de nos concitoyens
et c'était publié essai publié aux
éditions grasset merci encore à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat